in this video I'll show you how to write
a whole book in less than an hour using
a brand new AI tool so AI is getting
crazy nowadays a lot of AI tools claims
that they can write a whole book for you
but from all the testing that I've done
I think this tool and what I'm about to
show you is the fastest quickest and
simplest way to actually write a whole
book with AI and that tool is dibbly
create so I'm actually going to research
the book topic write the whole book
format it and get it ready to upload
right within this video so you guys can
follow along if you want to but let's
get started all right so in this video
let's try and write a book on
decluttering so I use decluttering as an
example topic often times but it's
because it's profitable right this book
right here is doing $82 every single day
right and this book right here as an
audio book is doing
$256 in royalties every single day not
counting the ebook in paperback so
decluttering is a very profitable topic
so going back to D create the first
thing we want to do is click on new
project and we're going to name this
decluttering book so we just call it
decluttering book so you can technically
start writing here right you can start
writing the intro you can also have Kip
which is the AI assistant that's
integrated into di uh to go and help you
write right so you can ask for a lot of
things like rewrite grammar correction
Etc so I can even say you know please
write an intro for a book on
decluttering and it'll go in start
writing the intro and I could also just
highlight this and ask for it to enrich
content which will just expand the
content even more so you can see that
one paragraph changed into a pretty long
solid uh block of text here so
technically you can start writing that
way but before we do so what I recommend
you do is go up here and there are a lot
of different templates that you can use
uh specifically for outline description
research Etc so the first thing we want
to do obviously before we start writing
is to research the topic right get to
know our customers get to know the book
topic better and learn actually what
people are looking for so there are many
many different things that you can
research within the research tab but
personally I like the Amazon search term
analysis the best so from here you can
change obviously to.uk different
Marketplace but I'm just going to put
decluttering right as the search term
and then we're going to put number of
books to five okay and from here we're
going to click on search now it's going
to take a couple minutes here to
generate the answer which I'm just going
to show you what I've generated
yesterday just because I'm filming a
video and I don't want to wait around
too long so essentially this is what uh
it generates right from this from this
question here so so we have our
competitor book number one here and if
you look down here it has the product
overview with basic information and then
from here it has the summary of the
review so it actually goes and reads the
review right and tells you information
from that so it tells you what the users
like the most about the book right it
also talks about the strengths the
weaknesses of the book and it also has a
Competitive Edge which I think is really
really cool basically talking about what
this book did uh to Stand Out Among the
crowd so we can definitely copy that or
MoDOT it so that our book can also stand
out right so that's a huge information
right there and then now we have keyword
analysis like what are the keywords but
basically this is the biggest one right
the Competitive Edge this information is
essentially telling us you know exactly
what the book is doing to stand out and
we definitely want to use that and
incorporate that into our books so going
down to it now we have book number two
same thing uh basically the same
information but book number two right
and now we have this very very
profitable book on decluttering uh we
can go and analyze it strengths
weaknesses right and the Competitive
Edge right so in terms of the
Competitive Edge right people like the
writing style and the language this is
what people are actually saying in the
review right so we definitely want to
keep in mind to keep our writing style
and language easy to understand and not
overly complicated we also probably want
to do something like written in a
relatable and humorous manner making it
engaging for readers uh I think that's
going to be pretty smart to do so so
that was the research section you
definitely want to do that before you
start writing to have a better
understanding of what you should be
writing about right and going back to it
so this is the exact same generation
that you know came out which is what I
just showed you here and the cool thing
is you can always save the output that
you got in the noes section so that you
can refer back to it every single time
all right so now that we've done the
research now we're going to go and
create our book title so there's a
template for that too so let's click on
title generator we're going to click on
non-fiction you can do this for fiction
as well a brief description would be a
book on decluttering um uh even if
you're a busy adult okay uh audience I
would just do adults I'm going to click
book here and for the category I just
chose crafts hobbies and home Home
Improvements and how to Home
Improvements uh which I think is the
closest to this topic and you can click
on search and once again this is the
answer that I got so we have title ideas
for decluttering so we got top related
keywords first off uh to give you more
ideas right so home organization
decluttering tips mindful decluttering
clut control those kind of things
average price for a book Common topics
and Concepts right which is useful and
then it gives us the potential titles
right it g actually gives us a title so
we have simplify and reclaim a busy
adults guide to decluttering and
organizing your home the path to
Serenity unlocking the secrets of
declaring your home as a busy adult from
chaos to calm the Art of Letting Go so
we got some good ideas here and then we
also got some potential subtitles of the
book so practical tools and inspiration
for busy adults on the decluttering
journey overcoming overwhelmed and
creating a tranquil sanctuary in your
busy adult life so out of all this uh my
favorite is the decluttering revolution
as a title just because I want the
keyword in the title somewhere so that I
can rank you know SEO wise so that's why
I want the word decluttering in it so
the decluttering revolution does sound
good and instead of using this uh
subtitle I want something a little more
descriptive so I'm going to choose this
one as my subtitle overcoming overwhelm
and creating a tranquil sanctuary in
your busy adult life all right so now
that we've done the research right now
we have the title the next thing is we
want to go and create our outline so we
go back to the outline here and change
the audience to adults obviously this
depends right if you have different book
topics it could be children teenagers
seniors I'm going to change this to
non-fiction number of chapters I'm going
to put 10 uh typically 8 to 12 is the
average but this is up to you number of
words we're going to change just to
30,000 Words which is going to be about
150 pages so I've entered my book title
the decluttering revolution I would say
the genre of the book is Home
Improvement main topic is decluttering
and for the explanation of the book I
just put a book on decluttering your
home filled with practical tips and
strategies to reduce clutter stress and
overwhelm even if you're a busy adult so
you just kind of want to explain your
book a little bit and click on generate
and this is the outline that I got so
this is actually extremely detailed and
it's honestly pretty impressive what you
can do with AI within minutes right so
it's it's really really cool but this is
what we got so the decluttering
revolution overcoming overwhelmed and
creating a tranquil sanctuary in your
busy life the manuscript requirements uh
we have the niche of the book size of
the book this is just basic information
the objective of the manuscript is to
provide practical decluttering tips and
techniques that can easily be
implemented by busy adults help readers
understand the connection between the
cluttering and reducing stress and
overwhelm in their daily lives right
what's the manuscript about it is a
comprehensive guide to declining and
organizing your home empowering busy
adults to create a Serene and harmonious
living environment the key takeaways we
have the questions readers would want
answered by reading this manuscript so
these are the questions readers W right
how can I effectively decluttering my
home without feeling overwhelmed what
are the benefits of living in a
clutter-free environment so these are
pretty good target audience is busy
working professionals and homeowners why
the audience will read this book top
books in this Niche so we got competitor
books we even got the style and the tone
so it says the writing style will be
informative practical and engaging we
even got competition analysis and then
from here it goes into the actual
chapters so it's already really really
detailed but this is where gets crazy
detailed because every single chapter
here right we got chapter one we have
the summary we even have sub points
right so not just getting the chapter
we're getting sub chapters or sub points
and then within each sub points we have
one two three bullet points and on top
of that each bullet points has four
ideas so it just breaks this down into
such detail level that if you're going
to actually start filling out the
outline and runting it it's so easy to
follow because it's super super super
detail right so subo 2 we got so much
bullet points inside subo 3 a ton of
bullet points subo 4 and here's the
thing we even got reference links that
we can go and actually research on this
topic about right so potential links
that we can incorporate inside the book
and so the fact that it's pulling links
from online sources is pretty huge okay
so that was chapter one chapter two is
the same thing right same structure it
has the potential links for chapter 2
chapter 3 The Art of minimalism um sub
points and we have the potential link so
it just keeps going for the rest of the
outline all right so now we're actually
going to go and write this book right
which is ADD simple as once again going
back to Kip generate here click on
content writer and we're going to keep
it a book chapter non-fiction and for
the chapter outline we're going to paste
our chapter outline so we're going to
click on chapter one drag it all the way
down until the potential links so don't
add the potential links here going back
here pasting it in and this is the
important part you want to include
sources uh because this will from my
experience uh make the output so much
better because the AI is actually going
to research articles blog post YouTube
videos online right and then they will
even site sources and all that uh and
they will do all that for you so you can
add your links but you know I recommend
using this one at least from my
experience the output was much better so
for the tone I'm just going to keep this
set objective and narrative writing for
the target audience I'm going to go back
up here and just get the target audience
from the outline paste it here and click
on generate and this is a chapter that I
got so understanding the impact of
clutter on mental well-being having a
home filled with clutter can make you
feel like you're constantly stuck in a
mess where calmness seems impossible to
find and even simple daily task feel
like huge obstacles the clutter in our
home doesn't just take up space
physically also invades our minds
creating a stressful and uncomfortable
mental environment and what not right so
it's pretty good pretty detailed and
from here obviously you can rewrite it
you can use Kip to rewrite correct the
grammar uh change the point of view so
if you want to change this to let's say
first person second person third person
I think it'll be pretty useful
especially if you're doing fiction uh
you can do that you can change the
writing style here to whatever you want
to do you can simplify enrich and so
much more right so yes you can write the
book just using AI but it's probably a
better idea if you can you know add your
own input change it up a little bit so
that it's actually your book right so
you wrote the book with the help of AI
but it's still your book rather than a
100% AI generated book you know but even
if you just use AI you can see that it
it's actually pretty good it's
impressive so going back to it so this
is the entire chapter I'm just going to
scroll down and you can see that we got
key strategies for creating a tranquil
organized space and then we have the
links used in this uh chapter so that
you can put it in the reference page
later on so you basically want to repeat
this process next we take chapter 2 copy
this paste it back into the chapter
outline and then we make sure this is
tackled on make sure the tone and the
writing style is the same right choose
the same one so the the everything is
congruent throughout the book and we
click on generate and this is what I got
for chapter 2 so practical declaring
tips for busy professionals uh and then
we go down to the 10-minute decluttering
rule so now it's actually going into
like the tips and strategies right so we
have the Crux of the 10-minute rule is
simple spend just 10 minutes a day
focusing on organizing a specific spot
like your work desk a closet what's
wonderful about this approach is its
Simplicity and how it transforms the
daunting task of decluttering into
something doable and less time intensive
right so you know it just keeps going
like that so that is chapter 2 same
structure so keep going and repeat this
process for chapter 3 chapter 4 5 6 79
10 and what I also recommend you do is
save this to note so after you generate
the answer you want to save it to note
which will show up in this notes section
you can see that I've done exactly that
right so I have the the research the
title outline chapter 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so
just to show you a few more examples
what I found to be the most impressive
part of this is that it's again you know
just pulling sources from online
articles and whatnot and it's
referencing that right so in chapter 6
there's a section that says according to
home enhancement experts and Home and
Gardens the onein one out principle in a
is a powerful tool in turning your
spaces into efficient peaceful places
where Essentials are always Within Reach
instead of hitting among unnecessary
duplicates and it even you know sight s
mid content like this uh which is pretty
crazy pretty crazy so anyways once you
have all your chapters generated uh what
you want to do is copy it and go down to
the actual sections because this is just
a note section it's not going to show up
in the actual book so we want to put it
in the sections here which is what I've
done right so I pasted in the section I
put the chapter heading I have the body
here and then from here you can format
it right so you can click on align what
we want to do is justify uh because
that's the the proper formatting for the
book and you can do additional
formatting additional rewriting uh you
know Bolding italicize whatever you want
to do repeat this process for chapter 2
chapter 3 chapter 4 right and just keep
going and once the book is ready it's
time to export it and the cool thing is
you can even format within dibl uh
directly so come up here click on export
so you do have some basic formatting
here which looks like this right so you
can see the preview and it looks okay uh
actually looks pretty nice but you can
also create a custom formatting you know
the way you want it to be right and then
this is how it looks and I like the way
this looks uh so I'm going to show you
how you can do the same so first I'm
going to go up to advanced settings and
then you have different options here you
have the option for table contents I
generally stick to Georgia as a font uh
and you can you know kind of play around
with that as well what's important is
you want to enter your title and the
subtitle in the title page so after I
entered it it looks like this you can
play around with the fonts as well you
can even put your author name all right
so that is how it looks now come down to
headers and Footers uh it's up to you
and what you want to do I Ally choose
this one so that I have the page number
as well as the author and the title on
the top so you can see that uh now we
have the author name and the title
showing up but the font is different
right so we want to change the font to
to Georgia here because I think Georgia
looks nice and this is how it looks now
so a lot cleaner so next for the chapter
heading uh you have some options once
again you can align this to the center
we could also put uh different options
of like chapter one or you know how the
chapter shows up so I put that here uh
and you can see that it's in the center
but it's kind of you know on the top of
the page we want to lower it so we can
uh adjust the margin all right so I
changed the margin top to four and the
margin bottom to two so there's a little
space between the chapter one and also
the actual chapter title you can even
change this to regular not bold and I
think that looks pretty good so next for
the paragraph you have some options here
you can do drop caps it'll look like
this I think it looks nice so I'll just
keep it as this and we also got the
heading setting as well as the margins
but I will uh keep this as is so the
last thing you want to do is make sure
you go through the entire book make sure
it looks nice but as you can see guys
this looks pretty professional already
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
export and this is the final product so
we have 120 Pages generated within
literally 20 minutes or 30 minutes right
and then we have the title page we got
the table contents the table contents uh
you can clean this up even more you
don't have to show you know sub chapters
you can just do chapter headings this is
something I can go back and fix it uh
for now I'll keep it as is right uh but
we got chapter one we have the sub
chapters and then it just keeps going
like that chapter 2 chapter 3 and so on
so obviously it's not perfect right once
again you should probably read through
the entire book make sure all facts are
correct uh make sure you edit some parts
add some parts right so that you know
it's it's your book it's not just a AI
written book right but combining AI to
speed up the entire writing process I
think this is getting pretty crazy in
terms of what you can do with AI it
saves you a lot of time because it's so
much faster to generate a baseline
content where you can go and edit from
uh than trying to write everything from
scratch so the goal with AI writing is
not to sacrifice quality and publish a
book as fast and as cheap as possible
where you're just basically spamming
lowquality crap that's not what we're
trying to do here right the ultimate
goal of AI writing is to be able to
write a book that's much better than if
you would write it without Ai and for
most of us that could be the case
because I'm a horrible writer right
English is my second language so if I
try to write a book from scratch it's
going to be way worse than what I could
generate uh using Ai and then try and go
and touch it up later on and I think a
lot of people can relate to that so if
you guys want to check out di crate I'll
leave a link below this video I believe
you get a little discount if you use the
link in my description uh but anyways
they have two different tiers right they
got the free tier so you can play around
with it uh with the free one and you
know if you like you can upgrade it and
they also obviously got the the PID tier
as well now if you're wondering you know
why don't I just use Chad jpd why don't
I just use other AI tool well if you're
trying to get the quality of output that
you're getting from dibl crate you
probably have to pay for GPD 4 or you
know the paid version of other AI tools
anyways so you're probably going to be
paying for those anyways and those AI
tools aren't made specifically for
publishing right Dil create is
specifically for us right what we're
trying to do sell publishing books on
Amazon KDP and also it's going to save a
lot of time because with gp4 and other
you know AI tools you still have to
figure out the prompting you still have
to learn the prompting with d crate you
can see that there was absolutely zero
prompting because everything is already
set up in the back end so you just give
it the information that it's asking for
and it gives you the answer that you
want so the biggest benefit is that it
saves time and we all know that time is
money right you don't want to try and
save 10 bucks a month 20 bucks a month
uh by spending an extra 5 10 hours
because you probably would have made so
much more just working a minimum wage
job you know within that 5 to 10 hours
than trying to save 10 20 bucks trying
to do this yourself if that makes sense
anyways hope you enjoyed the video leave
a like subscribe if you haven't yet uh
let me know if you have any questions in
the comment section below thanks for
watching and see you guys in the next
one